donald trump has developed a novel
business model he gives out valuable
primary endorsements to establish
republican officials and wannabe party
nominees and they visit him at one of
his many properties paying for food
lodging and conference space so far he's
collected at least 1.4 million dollars
from the candidates he's endorsed in
2022 according to a forbes analysis of
campaign disclosures
house minority leader kevin mccarthy has
spent the most so far shelling out 252
000 at trump properties 99 of which came
between trump's election in 2016 and the
end of his term
another big spender is senate hopeful
herschel walker of georgia the former
heisman trophy winner who played for
trump's new jersey generals of the now
defunct usfl doled out 199 000 at
mar-a-lago in less than a year
rounding out the top five spenders is a
trio of first-time candidates john gibbs
who served as assistant housing and
urban development secretary under trump
and is now running for congress in
michigan has spent 98 000
former trump press secretary sarah
huckabee sanders now contending for
governor in arkansas dropped ninety
thousand dollars and kari lake a
one-time news anchor at a fox affiliate
in phoenix shelled out seventy thousand
dollars amid her bid to become governor
of arizona
it's likely trump collected more than
the 1.4 million dollars forbes was able
to identify some states do not require
candidates to itemize their expenses
including south dakota whose governor
christie noam has made multiple trips to
trump properties